[Music]
the japanese archipelago' 20 years in
the future
[Music]
canine saturation has reached epidemic
proportions an outbreak of dog flu
ripped through the city of Mecca sake
mayor Kobayashi issues emergency orders
calling for a hasty quarantine
trash island it becomes an exiled colony
the Isle of Dogs I don't think I can
stomach any more of this garbage same
here words out of my mouth
nobody's giving up around here and don't
you forget it
ever your Rex your king your Duke your
boss I'm chief we're a pack of scary
indestructible alpha dogs Atari
Kobayashi you heroically hijacked a
junior turboprop XJ 750 and flew it to
the islands because of the dog
darn it I've got a crush on you we get
the idea you were looking for your lost
dog spots
does anybody know sparks if he's alive
may very well be living even at this
moment as a captive prisoner somebody is
up to something will you help him why
should I because he's a 12 year old boy
dogs love those
we'll find him wherever he is if he's
alive we'll find your dog
where somebody spoke his language
Wow to the north a long rickety causeway
over noxious sludge marsh leading to a
radioactive landfill polluted by toxic
chemical garbage that's our destination
great get ready to jump
[Music]